تم اخلائهم كلهم لا تستغرب انها الفوضى
فتوقع اي شيء تقدر وسائل اعلام غربيه عدد
السجناء الفارين من السجون السودانيه منذ
بدء النزاع المسلح بنحو 20 الف
المساله تاخذ ابعاد مختلفه مع اتضاح ان
بينما فارو رموزا في النظام السابق
ليس الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير بينهم
فالجيش السوداني اكد رسميا انه لا يزال في
مستشفى علياء التابع للقوات المسلحه لكن
لمصلحه من هروب او تهريب بعض من ابرز
مساعديه والمسؤولين في نظامه
باسرع مما يمكن لاحد ان يتوقع يرسم
القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الوطني المنحل
والمطلوب لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه احمد
هارون خريطه طريقه ومن معه
وقوفنا معكم في خندق الوطن لمنع اختطافه
لصالح مشروع اسري مدعوم دوليا واقليميا
تعلم الجهه التي يقصد بانه يقصدها لكن
قوات الدعم السريع ترى في خروج قيادات في
نظام عمر البشير من السجون ما تصفها
بممارسه تظليليه مكشوفه تهدف الى استعاده
النظام السابق
وتلك رؤيه تشاطرها قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي فماذا عن الجيش الذي يدعو
هارون الشعب السوداني للالتفاف حوله
نئى الجيش السوداني بنفسه عن كل تلك
التطورات اذ ان سلطه الاشراف على سجون
البلاد كما اوضح تقع خارج نطاق اختصاصه
لكنه وزاره الداخليه السودانيه لا تتردد
في اتهام قوات الدعم السريع بالمسؤوليه عن
الاضطرابات والجرائم الخطيره التي
ارتكبتها في حق البلاد كما قالت ومنها
اقتحام عدد من سجون البلاد واطلاق سراح من
سمتهم عوتات المجرمين
لا يجد مراقبون بددا بالمقاربه مساله
الخروج الكثيف والمباغت من السجون من
زاويه سياسيه
والا لما تبادل الجيش والدعم السريع
الاتهامات بتهيئه الظروف لما حدث في كوبر
وغيره من السجون فكل طرف يحمل الاخر
مسؤوليه محاوله تجهيير الفوضى لمصلحه
اجندته السياسيه
والقراءات السياسيه لعوده قيادات من حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل الى واجهه الاحداث
قد تتباين لكنها جميعا تضع المساله في
السياق العام لتطورات اللاهبه في البلد
وتتوقع ان هذا المعطى الجديد سيعمق حاله
الاستقطاب الحاده في اصلها ويزيد لا ريب
من تعقيد المشهد السوداني باكمله